nunavut is home to just under 40 000
people
scattered across an arctic landscape the
size of western europe
most are indigenous inuit and they live
in precarious conditions
few jobs expensive housing and by the
standards of a rich country like canada
minimal health services in the remote
hamlet of igloolik
north of hudson's bay there's only a
four bed health center
to serve two thousand people we have a
health system that is already at
capacity beyond capacity really
you know and and that it can't really
burn
much more um and then so when something
like this comes to play
it really puts those things to
perspective even in the territory's
largest town at calaweet
there are just seven ventilators in the
most basic of hospitals
proper intensive care can only be
accessed after a three-hour flight
south to the canadian capital ottawa the
people of nunavut
are also far more likely than other
canadians to have pre-existing medical
conditions
that are aggravated by covid19 so higher
levels of diabetes
chronic lung disease copd
chronic obstructive lung disease you
know given coronavirus tends to target
those people with
underlying health conditions it's it's
very concerning
so nunavut has effectively gone into its
own version of social isolation
no casual outside visits are allowed
returning residents can only come home
after they've quarantined for two weeks
travel between communities
is only permitted for medical or other
emergencies even a low number of covid19
cases
would be catastrophic up here that's why
there's a lot of local support
for isolating the entire territory it's
not an easy
position to be in so i'm very happy with
uh with the leadership that we've seen
on that level it's the federal
government
that needs to step up and assist
immunity
and provide the basic human rights that
everybody deserves
in the territory even before this
pandemic and the near shutdown of the
global economy
nunavut had lower life expectancies and
higher rates of poverty than most of
canada
remote and cut off at the best of times
this is a land that's hoping that kovid
19
leaves them alone with their existing
problems even as it ravages
the rest of the world daniel lack al
jazeera